ciao a tutti bentornati su anita rist
allora oggi video unboxing ho ordinato
un mistery box da amazon
sì lo so che state vedendo molti video
mistery box probabilmente ora su youtube
questo trend è nato da youtube america
prima di aprirla video che dire una cosa
importante state attenti se anche voi
volete ordinare per il mister e ai box
perché ci sono tantissime fregature
online giallo su amazon e su ebay era
una scatola la riempiono di mondezza
davvero o anche roba da far roma vecchia
cose assurde anche per prezzi sordi come
500 1100 che la gente riempie le scatole
di schifezze poi le invia con la scusa
che sono mystery quindi che non si sa
cosa c'è dentro possono mettere quel
cavolo che vogliono quindi anche
mondezza e ruba terribile non del valore
della scatola di oggetti dentro non
corrispondono per favore quindi dovete
stare superate se volete mettere una
mise box quello che vi consiglio per non
essere fregati e innanzitutto guardare i
feedback
guardate il feedback e sono tantissimi
feedback relativi a un oggetto proprio
potete appunto scendere giù vedere i
feedback sulle altre persone potete
anche vedere il feedback del venditore
cliccando sul nome del venditore
lo stesso su ebay purtroppo non ci sono
i feedback reati
l'oggetto che lo potete cliccare nel
sito del venditore e vedere cosa ha
scritto la gente se hai ricevuto non
fregature e io cosa ho fatto allora
stavo cercando appunto una mistery box
interessante sono tanto su amazon che ha
trovato questa mistery box che veduta e
spedite da quindi non è un altro
venditore non è un privato un venditore
terzo e proprio amazon che rea che ha
creato questa mistery box l'ho comprata
io non è una pubblicità ma allora quadro
pagata io ho dovuto pagare anche altre
sezioni per quarto del totale era sui 50
euro però in italia la spedizione dopo
punto 8 sono gratuite e quindi messi a
non sbagliare sui 40 euro poi magari
troviamo una messa a fregatura cosa
dentro magari a mazzuchi ho messo dentro
della carta igienica tipo immaginate che
amazon inizia a fare queste trovate che
rivivere marito nella descrizione che
gli articoli qua dentro hanno lo stesso
valore di quanto ho pagato quindi
andiamo alla tripla schemi e poi nei
commenti potrete dare il voto a ogni
articolo che c'è qua dentro siete pronti
iniziamo enorme che diventa scotto là
dentro
questa è la vita di boxe l'anno
ricoperta con la carta con scritto
mistery box sopra potete capire l'idea
di ricoprirla ok aperta ok non vado a
guardare dentro ma infilò la mano e
prendo la prima cosa che scoppia c'è un
foglio e non so perché mai scritto in
spagnolo nonostante abbia ordinato dalla
maggior italia c'è qualcosa che non
quadra
comunque sentito grazie per aver
acquistato la mistery box di neo che
oggi più
spero che vi piaccia vediamo prendo una
cosa a caldo io cos'è allora scritto
illusioni ottiche e ci sono degli
occhiali interessante che apre ha voluto
che sono già tutti scientifici con una
serie di kit di esperimenti e questi
esperimenti sono fisici e si possono
realizzare in casa scusate sopra
versione dallo spagnolo con un po di
pazienza e sporto imparerai a creare la
tua vera magia
[Musica]
ok allora ci sono degli occhiali a
quanto pare comunque facile ok questi
sono gli occhiali prima devono montare
gli occhiali e poi possono dare te
fedeli e luigi mio ok ragazzi ho
preparato gli occhiali scusate sono un
po tutto morte non li ho voluti
ritagliare bene perché voglio provarli
il prima possibile
allora fa dentro ci sono le illusioni
ottiche andiamo a sera lettori poi
mettiamo gli occhiali e vediamo cosa
vediamo anche se non so dalla camera poi
prova a mettere gli occhiali nella
camera allora praticamente questo qua
con le strisce te lo devo passare sopra
questi dovrei vederli muoversi
oppure ci sono questi che dovrei vedere
in 3d allora prima provo vedo servendo
qualcosa e poi propone sul nella letto
nella camera vediamo se si vede che
allora sì il cad e sembra un po 3d
l'effetto non è super
wow come quando vai al cinema e vedi
film itri di bree è molto carino perché
insomma pur avendo solo gli occhiali
così l'effetto è bello
ok vediamo queste personaggi
sì lo stesso l'appello 3d non è appunto
su super wow però è molto carino insomma
e poi abbiamo questa è quest'uomo questa
non so perché ma questa sembra più 3d
delle altre e vediamo se funziona
mettendo qui gli occhiali non so quanto
mettere i vicini comunque voi
avvicinatevi un po allo scoperto un
pezzo che poteri questa cosa proviamo lo
stesso
no sono con quella rossa non si vede
nemmeno solo quello si può fare questa
cosa
peccato vediamo se provo a mettere le
lenti una sopra la ecco con le lenti una
sopra l'altra non si vede proprio un bel
niente
purtroppo non vi posso far vedere questa
illusione ottica però me ne posso far
vedere un'altra cioè questa
in pratica il 7 sul foglietto qua e
bisogna far muovere questo dietro vedete
spero che si vede in camera in pratica
sembra che questo si stia muovendo
guardate sembra che la ruota si muova
non so se funziona no così non funziona
solo così funziona vedere le altre
immagini
non capisco in realtà che cosa sia
quella cosa dietro però sembra che
simula fatemi sapere nei commenti se lo
vedete che si muove l'immagine dietro o
se non vedete che si mi vedete il
cuoricino anche io lo vedo che si muove
dal quale allo schermo quindi dovreste
riuscire a vederlo anche questo è
ipnotizzante
questo è fichissimo sub e tantissimo e
superino ti tante questo è l'ultimo che
non ho capito 613 una s for the rest
editori bene quindi questa era la prima
cosa nella scatola che voto lido a
questo primo oggetto di dono di stealth
allora i materiali non sono granché come
potete vedere cartoncino e dei foglietti
di carta per ogni sospette perché è
comunque molto carina come idea e
divertente vorrei delusioni ottiche con
gli occhiali a per e poi nei commenti
che voto date a questo primo oggetto era
possono secondo oggetto appena
guardare qualcosa di grande e questo non
ci posso credere come uno strano perché
mi piace lucchetti uno scooter
telecomandato ora fatto ad offrirlo mi
sono dimenticato di dire tra l'altro se
questo video raggiunge i 10 mila l'ice
andrò a comprare altre mistery box ea
fare l'unboxing con voi perché mi
diverte truffare l'unboxing di queste
sorprese e fatemi sapere miei commenti
che tipo di essere box volete vedere
fanno quest'anno una visita all hope ure
magari un'altra di queste vediamo
insomma se le altre cose che ci sono
delle persone interessante allora c'è un
problema in questo caso per mettere i
batteri bisogna evitarlo e lascia anche
qua quindi sono andato a recuperare
questo cacciavite ovviamente tutto
questo succede mentre non c'è vitale
quindi dopo quando io perché l'esperto
in queste cose
allora cioè ho smontato tutto oppure qua
e ci vogliono le batterie aa quelle
piccoline per verdure o visitare la
posta non c'è di batterie e ne compra
sempre per tutti i tipi e sceglierò qua
tra l'altro sono anche giuste qua dro
gene vogliono 4 quindi per fortuna tutto
sono anche riuscito a sfruttarlo quindi
ora andiamo a metterle e vediamo come
funziona è incredibile ho fatto una cosa
incredibile
ora ci siamo pronti per provarla
spaventare il capino azioniamo perché
non funziona non la pazienza ok ora
vediamo se tira avanti
ok vabbè animi si divertì che crede
allora provo per terra date un po che
faccia arrabbiata a hello kitty uomo che
invece lei in quanto è tranquilla ma che
cosa è quello il foulard che sta volando
di comunque vediamo quanto intenda
incidere un gatto un cane così sarebbe
ancora più divertente
vediamo quanto va veloce no perché mai
in frenata da impegna in penna in
pendant no no no non sbattere
no no no impenna vediamo se ne son a
farlo tornare qua da me ragazzi fatevi
scappare con tanto posso far fare a
questi due è look hippy telecomandata
vieni qua e voto date il secondo oggetto
gliel'ho kitty telecomando che allora io
gli do un botto perché secondo me super
divertente ma qualsiasi e poi a me
piacenza a quello kitty quindi e penso
che sia divertente sia per un master che
per una femmina
quindi gli do un 8 voi che voto guidata
da una ditta sento qualcosa di piccolo
ok allora queste sono delle carte del
gruppo f con so cosa voglia dire a me ne
vada se però penso che sia con le specie
in estinzione
quindi andiamo ad aprirle chiediamo che
se sono disegnati fa dietro il singolo
del web e davanti abbiamo il panda i
gorilla di teschi niente sono tanti
animali purtroppo in estinzione che è
abbastanza triste il veramente e queste
carte mi ricordano una cosa che vi dico
sempre di non andare al circo perché è
una crudeltà degli animali tolti dal
loro ambiente naturale e buttati in
quelle gabbie solo bear business persone
veramente crudele non andate al circo in
un po anche se che siano molto carine
queste carte non è niente di speciale
e bello avere tutto delle cartelle west
che ci ricordano anche quali sono le
specie in estinzione
sapete io amo gli animali comunque
questo terzo oggetto gli do un 7 lo
stesso perché non è niente di
particolarmente speciale però è ok
quarto oggetto penso che mi manchino
ora questa cosa una cosa ma forse caduta
ad uno stop è stata messa di così
io non conosco questo personaggio ha
forse sì materne di dito
sanremo c'è scritto forse è caduto con
la scatola di hello kitty perché sanrio
la stessa marca brand di hello kitty
comunque si mette il dito sulla matita
questo era il quarto oggetto beh questo
somma di do un
4 perché non è niente di che ma almeno è
un aggiunto oggetto allora se non voglio
né mancano solamente due purtroppo guido
oggetto che cos'è questa cosa cristalli
going questo quindi cristalli che
crescono ma il crescere del tuo albero
koper ricoperto di cristalli in qualche
ora bonsai che strano andiamo ad aprirlo
che tutta la collezione e quindi in
pratica poteva capitarmi uno di questi
immagino che sono un pappagallo sun
gonzález di notavano un albero e mi è
capitato di bonsai
apriamo lo vediamo come funziona questa
cosa c'e dentro un liquido bravo un
cartoncino un foglietto che immagino che
saranno le istruzioni
è questa coppetta franchiste nient'altro
allora le istruzioni sono cortissime
devo solo fare queste quattro cose e
potevo aspettare e crescono i cristalli
che in pratica deve montare questo
albero
ok ho montato l'albero potevo mettere in
questo contenitore giungere sempre si
mette mettere in questa cosa va detto
che i ragazzi una devo solo aspettare
però c'è scritto che ci potrebbero
volere varie ore quindi io lo appoggio
da qualche parte
poi vediamo un piano piano cosa
succederà che voto diamo all'oggetto
numero 5 purtroppo non possiamo dare un
voto senza aver vinto prima il risultato
però funziona mi sembra molto cool
il più dice anche quindi un po di
chimica facciamo un po di chimica mentre
si divertiamo infatti dice che potassio
di idrogeno orto fosfato k h 2b bonnefoy
vita primi commenti se volete vedere il
risultato di questo hardware con i
cristalli e ora stiamo purtroppo
arrivati all'ultimo oggetto il numero 6
mi sembra purtroppo è l'ultimo mi stavo
divertendo troppo tutto questo tutto il
giorno comunque vado a tirare fuori un
ultimo mi sembra un gioco di società con
un pinguino
andiamo ad aprire la vediamo meglio che
cosa ci ha detto reparti dentro tanto i
cubetti a cubetti di ghiaccio le
istruzioni la base i due martelletti ora
vanno sotto mutarlo così vediamo come
funziona
allora ragazzi ecco qua o mount altro il
gioco in pratica quasi sono i bar i
cubetti di ghiaccio al centro si mette
il pinguino questo gioco ed a2a fatto
giocatore infatti purtroppo visto che è
vitale non so non posso provarlo però vi
spiego come funziona in pratica bisogna
aggirare questa ruota rutina e in base a
quello che ti capita se ti capita questo
non devi tirare il martello sul ghiaccio
se ti capita questo devi tirare un
ghiaccio bianco nel piatto il burro o
questo quello che vuoi tu
in pratica ognuno quando il tuo turno di
ritirare un colpetto di ghiaccio e deve
cercare di non far cadere il pinguino
chi fa cadere il pinguino perde quindi
io ora proprio girare ed economy capita
mi è capitato il ghiaccio bianco quindi
provo non vedo come funziona
proprio buttare giù questo magari ok io
buttate giù uno però il pinguino non è
caduto buttiamo dentro un altro mi è
capitato acqua stati pò qua quindi posso
scegliere io butto giù questo ecco qua
già infatti ne sono caduti su due è il
pinguino è in pericolo il biglietto per
cadere ma vento ma avete capito come
funziona fatemi sapere nei commenti se
volete che provi questo gioco assieme a
evitare così vediamo un semi in cui io o
se vincerà allora che voto do a questo
ultimo oggetto numero 6 o 7 non mi
ricordo più
allora mi piace molto penso che ti do un
otto e mezzo perché penso che sia
divertente come gioco di società si può
giocare a punto con gli amici con la
famiglia è fatto abbastanza bene e il
concetto comunque cari per cercare di
non far cadere il pin fido note e mezzo
qualche voto date a questo ultimo
oggetto e niente purtroppo sono finiti
tutti se forse vedere un altro video box
in scatole misterioso e lasciate un bel
haj che a 10.000 la ex andrò farne un
altro fatevi sotto nei commenti cosa vi
è piaciuto
a me penso mi è piaciuta molto la moto
telecomandata assimo burke e la fa
perché sono curiosa di vedere appunto
come diventa non è successo niente
ancora lì di fermo niente
fatemi sapere nei commenti se volete
vedere come diventa nel prossimo video
di mister yambo vi faccio vedere come è
diventato se successo fatto che se sono
cresciuti questa sorta di cristalli
quindi fatemelo sapere nei commenti
ditemi cosa dei più di queste cose
trovate nella mente di boxe secondo voi
ne è valsa la pena considerando più
corta mi sempre 40 euro su amazon italia
io penso che unendo appunto il vallone
tutte le cose penso che ci siamo
il personale mossa contenta all'affitto
voglia di sapere quindi se volete
vederne altri e mi lasciò raffa al 34
cappellini e se potete cliccare se
volete vedere ad esempio i miei altri
video o lo shopping altra cosa che ho
comprato
se volete vedere i video divertenti
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione